the idea of critical race theory
[Music]
um can you to me explain so i'm an
engineer
and have not been actually paying
attention much unfortunately to the
these things none of the people in your
field were until it comes along and
smacks you in the face i you know i i've
had that line of thinking and you know
from mit
i i said well surely whatever you folks
are busy about yelling at each other for
is is a thing at harvard and yale
it's not going to yeah yeah of course
yes people in the stem subjects thought
it's not coming for us it can't come to
us and bang
well it's you know it hasn't quite been
banged engineering is more safe than
others yeah uh so not so let's draw a
line now between engineering and science
so
i think engineering is uh i'm uh sitting
in a castle in the tallest tower with
with my pinky out drinking my martinis
thing surely
uh the the peasants below with their
biology and their humanities
we'll we'll figure it all out no i'm
just kidding there's no there's no pinky
out i drink vodka
and i hang with the peasants okay where
is this this metaphor has gone too far
uh
can you explain
uh to this engineer what critical race
theory is is it a a term that's
definable is there tradition is there a
history what is good about it what is
bad about it is it is a tradition it is
a history as a school of thought it
started in the law uh roughly in the
1970s and some of the american academy
uh it's spilled out it always aimed to
be an activist philosophy people deny
that now but as i cite him in the war in
the west and the foundational texts say
as much this isn't this is an activist
um academic study
we're not just looking at
the law we seek to change the law
and it's built out into all of the other
disciplines i think there's a reason for
that by the way which is it happened at
the time that the humanities and others
in america were increasingly weak and
didn't know what to do and they needed
more games to play on new games to play
the psychologists got bored yeah i mean
that
well they needed tenure and they needed
they needed something to do and i mean
it's not an original observation plenty
of people have made this but i mean neil
ferguson said it some time ago for
instance that
in the last
50 years in american academia certainly
in humanities departments when some
when somebody dies out as a great
scholar and something that's just not
replaced by somebody of equal stature
they're replaced by somebody who does
theory
or
critical race theory they're replaced by
somebody who does the modern games
somebody dies out who's a great
historian off say i don't know it's the
ones on my mind um
russian history or russian literature
and they're not replaced by a similar um
scholar
in his observation in in yours is this a
recent development it's happened the
last few decades for sure and it's sped
up did is it because we've gotten to the
bottom of some of the biggest questions
of history no it's uh because we're
willing to forget the big questions
because it's more fun to big questions
aren't as fun no partly it's partly no i
should stress that partly isn't it this
is in the weeds but partly as a result
of the hype of specialization in
academia
um
you know if you if you said you'd like
to
write your dissertation on hobbs
uh if you wanted to
if you
said something central to cairns thought
or or hegel or something i mean that's
not
popular
that what's popular is to take somebody
way down the line from that because
there's a feeling that that's all been
done
so you take something way way way down
the line from that that's much less
important and then you sort of play with
that
and i think most people anyone who's
watching who's been in a philosophy
department or anything else in recent
years will know that
tendency by the way there's a very
practical consequence of this i saw this
at the end of my friend roger scrutin's
life when he um he would occasionally he
didn't get tenure at universities but he
would occasionally be flown in even by
his enemies to teach courses in various
universities in basics of philosophy
because there was no one in the
department able to do it
like
he would he would he would go in and
teach for a semester
you know
hegel and kant and schopenhauer and
others because
there was no one to do it because they
were all playing with things way way way
down the road from this
so that had already happened
and people were searching for new games
to play and the critical race theory
stuff forces its way in
partly in the way that all of this
that's now known as anti-racism does
which in a sort of bullying tone of
saying if you don't follow this the same
way that
all the things that are called studies
i think everything called studies in the
humanities should be shut down
because of the activist it's an accident
they're all activists
gay studies and queer studies
um nothing good has ever come from it
nothing good to push back is it is it
obvious that activism is a sign
of a flaw in a discipline so is isn't it
the sign of the death of the discipline
it's a sign that discipline's over
but isn't it a good goal to have for
discipline
to enact change positive change in the
world
or is that to is that that's for
politicians to do with the findings of
of science i mean not why create an
ideology and then set out to find
disciplines that have weakly put
together to try to back up your
political ideology so ideology should
not be part
of of uh of science or of no i mean
humanities why would you
i mean anyone could do it
you could decide to go in and be
wildly right-wing about something and
only do things that prove your right
wing ideas
be fantastically anti-academic
fantastically andy science fantastic
it's an absurd way to to mix up activism
and and and
and academia and it's absolutely rife
and critical race theory is one of the
ones that completely polluted the
academy
yeah and there's been uh dark moments
throughout history both for during world
war ii with both communism and uh nazism
fascism that
um infiltrated science
and then corrupted it yes i mean for
instance also let's face it
this in science as in everything else
there are dark difficult things
it's much better we know about them face
up to them and try to find a way
socially to deal with them
than that you leave them in the hands of
some activist
who wants to do stuff with them
some of my best friends are activists
i'm just kidding okay
none of my best friends are activists
that's how it should be
well i was kidding because i don't have
any friends but okay all right
now that's not true i'm trying to gain
some um
pity points okay uh so to return you
have your clubhouse friend
screaming away like
deranged maniacs
now andy clubhouse by the way because
the only time i heard it was that brett
weinstein one when
he did that i didn't if you heard that
early in clubhouse i was invited to
clubhouse by various people who said oh
this is a really great civilized way to
hang out and talk with interest
interesting people and i like downloaded
the app and i gone when i because brett
weinstein said um you know i'm doing
this conversation and i listened and it
was
the maddest damn discussion i've ever
heard was there something about biology
something about was it
uncovered times all that at some point
brett said i'm an um
i'm an evolutionary biologist
and somebody else that is saying you're
a eugenicist
and he said no i'm an evil evil issue in
my honesty and sometimes that's the same
thing
and it just went on like that and brett
desperately tried to explain
that's not the same thing as being
eugenicist and he lost the clubhouse
room
they thought that was the same thing
he'd come it horribly reminded me of a
time some years ago in a british
newspaper ran a sort of
realizing that the only thing you can
unite people on in sexual ethics is
revulsion against pedophilia ran an
antipedo campaign and uh shortly after
um
pediatricians offices were torched in
north of england by a mob who hadn't
read the whole sign yeah
well to me
um like i said a little bit of poison is
good for the town so anyhow sorry i
interrupted you with flattering you
there people on clubhouse i have many i
have i have
of multiples of friends yes
um
okay
we didn't get to some of the ideas of uh
critical race theory what what exactly
uh is it i'm actually in part asking
this question quite genuinely yeah it's
it's an attempt to look at everything
among other things through the lens of
race
and to add race into things where it may
not be
as a way of adding
i'm trying to give the most generous
estimation
to add race in as a conversation in a
place where it may not have been in the
conversation
um
and that means history too the history
racism yeah yeah yeah
all history
and to look at it through these
particular lenses
um
i mean there's a certain
like all these things there's a certain
logic in it like
like with feminist studies or something
i mean is is there a utility in looking
back through undoubtedly male dominated
histories and asking where the
the more silent female voice was yes
very interesting
not endlessly
and can't be put exactly on the same
par as
but
it has a utility
um it's that endlessly sorry to
interrupt that endlessly part that seems
to get us into trouble
well because of this thing of where do
you stop and that's
that's
that's always a
i looked and talked about this in my
last book in the manners of crowd
it's one of the big conundrums in
activist movements and particularly in
activist academia where would you stop
it's not clear because you've got a job
in it
you've got a pension in it
you've got
your only esteem in society is in
keeping this gig going
i mean is is there any likelihood have
you ever it's the old academic joke
isn't it that you know the end of every
conference the only thing everyone
agrees on is that we must have another
conference like this one
so one thing they always agree on this
conference has been so great we must
have another one well that's the
criticism you could apply to a lot of
disciplines of course civil engineering
bridge building
at a certain point do we need any more
bridges can we just fly everywhere
you know
so at the very least you need to keep
the bridges up
sure and they would uh critical race
theory folks would probably make the
same argument at the very least we need
to keep the racism out
uh let's make sure we don't descend into
uh the racism it assumes all the time
that we are living on the cusp of the
return of the kkk right which is totally
wrong
i mean it's a massive you say that now
until the kkk armies march in we don't
always we can't always predict the
future we can't always predict future
and
you you can always
say you should be careful but
you've also got to be careful of people
who've got their timing like totally
totally wrong or their estimation of
society they're in you mean like the
most
of society before in the 1930s
when hitler was
i mean so many people got hitler wrong
i'm sure they did and so most people
some
maybe it was nice to have the alarmist
thinking there well beware of the man
with a mustache
if only it was that easy
um
it's not always above facial hair i mean
i always say that i mean what what
very often is these two clean shaven
chaps both say
one of the problems of everybody knowing
a little bit about nazism
is that they
think that they know
where evil comes from and that it comes
from like a german with a small
moustache
getting people to goosestep for instance
and that's not correct
a much better understanding of it is it
can come from
all number of directions
and keep your antennae as good as you
can
but
once you end up in this society which i
would argue certainly parts of america
where you're always in 1938
that's not healthy for a society either
where where people are so primed and
think they're so well trained because
they
spent a term in school learning about
the second world war in the holocaust
think they're so well trained in hitler
spotting
that they can do it all the time look at
all these phrases we now have in our
societies like dog whistle
you know as i always say if you hear the
whistle you're the dog
but people say
that that's a dog whistle as if they're
highly trained anti-nazis
i mean you know there should be some
humility in it we should we should be
careful we should be wary for sure
and we should also be slightly humble
in our inability to
to spot everything
you